[Música]
escala en París Aída palao
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a todos a este espacio de
radio Francia internacional y France 24
la lucha contra el cambio climático pasa
por la reducción del dióxido de carbono
que se libera a la atmósfera y para
conseguirlo se tiene que reducir la
quema de combustibles fósiles como el
carbón el petróleo o el gas se imaginan
transportar mercancías en veleros pues
lo está haciendo una empresa francesa
desde hace 10 años con 64.000 millas
náuticas recorridas se han ahorrado 1500
toneladas de CO2 Hoy hace escala en
París una de sus fundadoras la
colombiana Diana mesa Diana muchísimas
gracias y bienvenida Gracias aitor bueno
el primer barco que flotaron junto a su
socio guillón Blake y su empresa taut
fue en 2011 y era una embarcación
neerlandesa que se llamaba tres hombres
construida en 1943 y dentro
transportaron cervezas Bio Cómo se les
ocurrió la idea y cómo fue esa primera
travesía Bueno pues esta idea nace de
una observación una constatación que
hemos tenido que es doble por un lado el
viento en altamar es abundante es
frecuente y desde hace algunos años es
predictivo también entonces la vela
desde a siglos es uno de los elementos
que puede
explotarla de la mejor del explotarlo de
la mejor manera Este es un constante el
siguiente es el transporte marítimo está
relacionado
interdependiente del petróleo Entonces
es muy muy complicado de carbonar por
razones tecnológicas lo que tú
mencionaste hace un momento por razones
comerciales el transporte es algo que
todos consumimos nuestros nuestros por
ejemplo gafas
y también en altamar Pues no hay leyes
tampoco que puedan regular esta de que
alguna nación entonces viendo esto
este reto de crear para
mercancías que tiene un valor agregado
Porque así es que hablan de su origen
valorizar estas mercancías con un
transporte que sea coherente donde un
transporte ecológico y respetuoso y esa
travesía fue bien Esa primera
es interesante Sí me acuerdo Este
era la primera en esta época no había
productos biológicos en
todas partes era digamos un producto un
poco
originario de este estuario el vestuario
etcétera entonces por eso lo escogimos
lo ya le pusimos el sello transportaba
en barco de vela y utilizamos este tres
hombres que está digamos uno de Los
Pioneros para transportarlo sin carbono
Este es un barco que no tiene motor y
pudimos hacer esta esta fuerza del
viento me gustaría que llegas también
que en ese momento también ya teníamos
nuestros primeros clientes que son
cooperativas View de Bretaña pero
también de Francia Bueno desde entonces
han transportado no solo cerveza café
colombiano rontes vinos chocolate qué
rutas están haciendo y Cuánto tarda un
producto por ejemplo en cruzar el
Atlántico o sea el café colombiano en
llegar a las costas
francesas es interesante porque pues son
rutas que son históricas siempre hemos
encontrado estas rutas por ejemplo la
del café está relacionada con Los
vientos alisios que va es como una
autopista en altamar Entonces por
ejemplo el año pasado transportamos un
café de Colombia que fue cargado
fines del año en diciembre y llegó aquí
a burdeos fue descargado en burdeos en
marzo o sea como a la antigua no como la
antiguamente no
usar esa fuente de energía encarece los
productos porque siempre muchas veces la
gente no es que utilizar energías
limpias hacer productos Bio luego todo
sale más caro en su caso sabe más caro
en nuestro caso con los veleros actuales
con los veleros con los que trabajamos
desde hace 10 años Es un costo realmente
importante y como tú dices porque no hay
esa capacidad de transportar mucha
mercancía y los barcos realmente no
están adaptados para esto es por esto
que nosotros desde el 2015 estamos
desarrollando un concepto de barco que
puede hacer más grande que pueda ser
optimizado para cargar y descargar la
mercancía Y así reducir los costos
entonces
lo que otra cosa con respecto al
transporte es que es algo que no
priorizado por ejemplo
un paquete de café en la parte de
transporte es son algunos céntimos
Entonces el aumento no va a representar
mucho en el mucha mucha diferencia en el
precio me decía que solo utilizan la
energía del viento no hay algo
alternativo por si falla algo y si no
hay viento por ejemplo Qué pasa
el tres hombres no tiene motor es algo
excepcional nuestros barcos modernos que
van a están siendo construidos en este
momento tienen un motor auxiliar porque
nosotros nuestro nuestra convicción es
que primero hay que ser fiables un
transporte fiable y frecuente entonces
necesitamos el motor en este momento
bueno por razones legales porque sin
motor es muy es imposible ir a los
puertos a los que pensamos ir pero
también el motor Lo vamos a utilizar
para mejorar nuestro trayecto a la vela
y ese motor Con qué energía va a estar
alimentado en este momento usamos un
motor que ya están probados y
es bien seguro entonces utilizamos una
combustión normal
[Música]
pero
está la parte donde vas a estar
instalada el motor ya está previsto para
un motor
eléctrico o de otro tipo de energía
cuando este tipo de energía ya está
híbrido con la proyección la idea de que
sea completamente
descarbonado Bueno me voy a dar unos
unos datos hoy en día el 90% del
comercio internacional se realiza a
través de la Marina mercante y el
transporte marítimo es el segundo sector
que más dióxido de carbono emite en el
mundo después de la generación de
Electricidad Mi pregunta es Es viable
que todo el transporte marítimo se haga
la vela
[Música]
si miramos los contenedores como es
transportado en este momento las
mercancías Es verdad que nuestro velero
puede parecer como una un granito de
arena o una cosa en el océano pero
nuestras perspectivas son de desarrollar
a una flota es por eso que el primer
barco no es uno sino dos barcos y la
idea es que la flota sigue creciendo
para poder asegurar a un transporte
frecuente que pueda
resolver responder a la necesidad de
nuestros clientes no vamos a transportar
todas las mercancías que en este momento
se transportan pero vamos a poder de
aquí a 2050 hemos calculado a 30% de
reducción de las emisiones del
transporte marítimo cuando les Proponen
a empresas transportar sus productos en
velero Cuál es la reacción entusiasmo
somos tan escépticos
desde el 2011 que hemos presentado el
proyecto es algo que hace ha cambiado
también al principio había como como tú
dices en escepticismo las personas
decían o no vamos a volver a una época
ya pasada pero también algunos Pioneros
que son ahora a nuestros primeros
clientes para el velero moderno sabía
que había algo que necesitaban para para
para terminar para poder completar la
cadena completa desde el productor hasta
el distribuidor de forma de carbonada Y
esa cadena esa parte es el transporte
marítimo para productos que vienen como
el café que no puede ser producidos acá
en Francia en Europa necesitan un
transporte de esta forma o sea el
elemento para finalizar un proyecto
coherente no finalmente es lo que
faltaba para que la coherencia se haga
desde el principio hasta el final nunca
son los clientes
que son muy entusiastas en realidad no
tenemos una relación de cliente y de
proveedor pero más dijo construcción ya
llevamos más de tres años desarrollando
el concepto del barco con ellos porque
es algo que que están convencidos es
también son visionarios porque es verdad
que hace unos años pues no era un tema
que se trataba la de carbonación no era
tan presente ahora ya es urgente Y
entonces ellos estuvieron ahí desde el
principio y hay muchas empresas
latinoamericanas que sí
desde el principio tenemos una empresa
latinoamericana los productores de
productos que ya han comenzado a
trabajar de forma armónica con la
naturaleza Es decir no utilizan ningún
químico para producir este tipo de
productores y o de exportadores nosotros
los hemos contactado desde hace mucho
tiempo y están son los más
necesitan y nos ayuden este tipo de
iniciativas para poder y
sectores son principalmente en Colombia
es verdad no es porque yo sea colombiana
pero es realmente ahí donde hay todavía
comunidades que cultivan de la forma
tradicional un juego Colombia pero
también México hemos transportado
también
semillas de cacao de México igual un
producto que llama al origen entonces
son Son ellos los más interesantes
aparte de mercancías también transportan
a personas no Cuánto cuesta un billete
si alguien quiere cruzar el Atlántico
por ejemplo se va a la costa francesa al
puerto Y dice Bueno yo quiero irme a
Colombia sí es algo que los otros cargos
también hacen pero nosotros lo que
proponemos es acompañar este tipo de
mercancía
de forma es un viaje un poco más largo
de pronto vas a tener que desconectarte
completamente Nosotros hemos previsto
por ejemplo actividades que van a
no no van a tener internet pero
actividades que van a ayudar a aprender
a la navegación conectarse como con otro
con ellos mismos va a ser como una
experiencia un poco más lenta y
es algo que principalmente está lo hemos
lo hemos propuesto también a los
clientes o a los productores ellos
mismos van a poder acompañar su
mercancía de un lado y cuánto cuesta un
billete por ejemplo si alguien quiere
tres propuestas allá en tus 150 euros al
día vale Bueno pues muchísimas gracias
Diana mesa ya no nos queda más tiempo
para abordar otros aspectos de este
transporte por velero y le deseamos
suerte Bueno muchísimas gracias Y
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que también
nos pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com y en France 24.com Hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]